[Musique]
depuis 55 millions de téléspectateurs y
sont venus par le métro nous rejoindre
sur le plateau d'aujourd'hui madame
qu'elle soit de paris devant lieux ou de
province comme elle près de 4 millions
de personnes prennent chaque jour le
métro pour se rendre à leur travail et
circuler dans paris
et pourtant l'histoire tout ce qui
touche au fonctionnement de ce moyen de
transport
vous en êtes encore méconnu
[Musique]
c'est le 19 juillet 2009 sans que la
première ligne de chemin de fer
métropolitain reliant la porte de
vincennes à la porte maillot et ouverte
au public
ce transport en commun urbain le plus
rapide jusqu'à ce jour
nous le devons à fulgence bienvenüe et
c'est le 30 mars 1898 dans la
perspective de l'ouverture de
l'exposition universelle que sa
construction fut reconnu d'utilité
publique ce qui mit fin d'ailleurs à
toutes les controverses la régularité du
métropolitain conquis d'emblée tous ceux
qui osèrent le prendre en dépit de
sinistres prédictions et de juillet à
décembre 1900 ils seront 17 millions 660
1286 à l'emprunter et près de 56
millions l'année suivante afin
d'explorer les coulisses du métro et de
mieux le connaître
aujourd'hui madame a retrouvé une de nos
téléspectatrices madame david qui elle
ya travaillé toute sa vie mais c'était
encore il ya quinze ans le métro
d'autres fois c'est avec un vif intérêt
qu'elle va redécouvrir celui de 1974 et
pouvoir imaginer celui de l'ordre de
1000 pour cette occasion madame david
est monté pour la cabine du conducteur
ce qu'elle n'avait jamais fait sa vie
quand êtes vous rentré comme receveuse
dans le métro en 38
pourquoi vous avez choisi ce métier
parce que je me suis trouvé veuve demain
un moment ali était jeu mignon sur la
ligne de saut alors la pression du siège
avait eu un emploi comme le sauvetage en
10 10 mai au chemin de fer et six mois
après y être là le métro a racheté la
ligue 2 sont alors comme on m'a dit tu
es en ligne de celui qu'ils auraient
opté s'il avait été là on j'ai demandé à
continuer aussi des monts fois c'est
comme ça que je suis j'ai atterri à la
nation de répit tant le chemin de fer en
c'est toujours la même machine celle là
que nous avions la sienne et première
classe mais deux secondes
quand vous étiez dans la ratp qu'elle
faut s'occuper vous au début j'étais
embauché comme celui d'entre eux sous
buzz je faisais le contrôle je
remplaçais les caissières à l'occasion
mais je n'avais pas de constituer le
premier pas qui c'était avant je faisais
la caisse ce que fait madame
ici nous sommes à montparnasse voudrais
pas que ça changera oui beaucoup surtout
la guerre entre la station et tout même
les caisses ont changé mais enfin cette
caisse là je l'avais vu moi aussi
seulement il ya eu de l'amélioration ne
font plus les quêtes il y a il ya des
caisses que je ne connais pas encore
mais enfin des stations qui ont beaucoup
changé
[Musique]
c'est qu'est ce que vous aimez mieux la
route ah oui vous êtes en france
en fait le contrôle si vous faites que
des caisses terminer son film tandis que
nous à l'aller blazy bien oui m'enfin
y'a m
parce que nous on s'était bien le coup d
envoi mais racontez moi comment
s'appelle ben c'était une station comme
il y en a encore beaucoup mais enfin
l'éclairage avec une rage des chantiers
y avait pas il fallait changer les
lampes des fois tu sois même si c'était
moins - mon rdv le décor là il est bien
oui mais surtout montparnasse
je ne connais pas moi qui n'étais pas
venu il ya longtemps parce que moi je
suis et la ligne 6 montagnac ac ce que
j'ai montana c'était pendant
l'occupation
ça fait quand même un moment à ce moment
là je faisais la ligne peu parce que on
nous faisait faire les dernières classes
comme les moitiés d'agents dans les
messieurs
et puis on faisait la vaisselle des fois
je suis même venu faire la caisse ici de
puces ils mettront c'est bien beau de
leucan quels différents rendez vous bah
c'est plus propre aux abois les voitures
sont plus confortables et voiture
c'était du moins les sièges en 2e classe
puis c'était toujours sale passe déjà
par le public et puis il faisait pas
attention c'est bien si vous voulez le
garder propre et un mot métro là
[Musique]
vous avez regardé le site nettoyé les la
station ah ben oui ça change est aussi
la ville avait des lieux ballet où il
fait sans laisser autant qu'ils en aient
pour le guider avec madame david à
travers le monde du métro nous sommes
adressés à une personnalité qui connaît
bien le métro et qui en a vécu toutes
les étapes de son histoire contemporaine
où sommes-nous ici me gâche et si nous
sommes au centre de surveillance de la
station auber du métro express régional
nous sommes situés sous la rue au vert
c'est une station du réseau express
régional qui comporte de nombreux
escaliers mécaniques qui en a 72 ici il
ya quinze ascenseur à surveiller il ya
quatre tapis roulant et pour pouvoir
surveiller tout cela donnait des
conseils aux voyageurs ou des
informations on doit disposer d'un
pupitre et d'un tableau synoptique cas
ouvriers derrière et d'un jeu des
comptes télévision qui nous permette à
tout instant de rentrer en contact avec
les voyageurs soit directement de notre
plein gré soit sur la demande de
personnes qui ont des difficultés avec
un escalier mécanique par exemple ou
avec un ascenseur mais je ne vois pas
beaucoup de voyageurs ici ah oui sinon
vous ne les voyez pas que nous sommes
dans un endroit qui sépare les flux de
voyageurs c'est pour ça que vous ne les
voyez pas sauf dans des endroits
spéciaux qu'on appelle les salles des
changes où là les entrants et les
sortants peuvent se rencontrer sinon les
deux flot de voyageurs sont parfaitement
séparer tout instant il ya combien de
voyageurs ornements de pointe aussi
c'est une station au think i à un débit
très important pour l'instant on peut
admettre qu elle
on va penser par jour sensiblement 200
mille voyageurs environ mais elle n'est
pas à sa capacité maximale puisque c'est
une station qui est conçu pour pouvoir
laisser couler cinquante mille voyageurs
à l'heure dans chaque sens comme tous
les rer d'ailleurs alors elle sera son
débit maximal lorsque le rvr traversera
paris de bout en bout lorsqu'à la
liaison sera lorsque le tronçon ouest et
le conseil sont raccordés ça prend
combien de kilomètres à la safra une
ligne de 46 km de long et ça ça sera
fait à la fin de 1977 qui vous messieurs
guemps je suis inspecteur principal au
service technique
j'étais conducteur sur la ligne
clignancourt orléans
et puis j'ai quitté je suis resté deux
ans conducteur puis ensuite j'ai passé
les concours qui lui ont permis de
penser dans les services techniques
[Musique]
en juillet 1900 qu'elle était la
longueur de la première ligne de métro à
ce moment là une phase de 10 km et en
1974 en comptant le réseau des
tripolitains celm on a en 175 kilomètres
de lignes
monsieur gage tout ça dans la station
abbès et je trouve que cette taxe ne
ressemble pas aux autres
pourquoi nous sommes actuellement sur
l'ancienne ligne paul du nord sud
c'était une compagnie disons concurrente
de la ratp
cette ligne du nord sud n'appartenait
pas au même groupe financier que le
groupe qui présidait aux destinées de la
compagnie du metropolitan paris alors le
nord sud se caractérisa d'ailleurs à
l'époque par un ils étaient plus luxueux
que le métro à l'époque la station et
baisse est à 32 mètres de profondeur
elle a été construite en 1910 1911
c'est une station guimard comme celle
douce il pas tout à fait parce que guy
marle décoré pour les stations dessus
c'était l'entrée guimard qui est
actuellement à la baisse du nantais qui
a été rapporté alors ces stations dit
marc ne disparaissent pas
systématiquement on les conserve
mais il ya des américains qui en ont
acheté pour les mettre dans des musées
comme témoin de de l'art moderne de
l'époque
david est ce que vous connaissiez la
station abbès je la connaissais pour les
avoir été quelquefois comme ça en forme
et je la connaissais pas spécialement je
me rendais pas compte qu'elle était si
profonde mais vous y travaillez la wii
là j'avais fait quelques remplacements
autres
vous avez des souvenirs personnels une
fois j'étais parti en congé je rentre
assez tôt pour mon service et puis dans
mon idée avec mon papier le commerce
était admettons le 28 inclus et moi je
réponds si j'apprenais que le 29
alors je suis j'étais chez moi bien
tranquille il fallait que mon chien fait
même passer même si j'étais lente et
j'étais pas la main le lendemain je m'en
remettrai plus loin mon travail en étant
supplantera valeurs iliad nous voilà
mais vous étiez pas manquer ce qui se
passait mais il savait que ça va vous
coûter cher
l'écurie merci surtout que j'étais
rentré dans l'ensemble si j'étais même
profité de dire je suis pas rentré mais
j'étais rentré en étant sûre d'être un
jour avance alors lâche étaient bien
contrôlés puis ça va coûter quand même
une punition il a fallu passer par
l'inspecteur c'était sur l'entretien et
ça me détend et ryanair à wissous si
c'était si c'était pas notre impôt faut
bien que le maître le magicien ou non
mais par ce dimanche à ce moment là on
avait pu lire cette semaine dans le
métro il y avait des îles pauvres
malheureux avec un accordéon
on les faisait même partie des
entreprises est resté trop longtemps
parce qu'il n'avait pas le droit
il faut en laisser parce que c'était des
maliens s'étaient pas indiqué
david vous connaissiez bien sûr cette
station auber opéra oui je vous le dis
jamais aubert la nouvelle là je l'avais
pas encore déjà sa masse est le plus ça
m'a fait sourire les belles choses je ne
pensais pas même quand on en parlait
sans l'avoir vu je ne vais pas je ne
voyais pas ça comme ça c'est agréable
ces douces et calmes dans le bios et
c'est quelque chose de bien
non et vous avez été surprise par ces
gigantesques couloir à huy les couloirs
et puis toutes ses magasins de ce qu'il
ya autour là c'est des choses super
d'esprit vous trouvez que les
correspondances on le fait c'est bien
d'indiquer la voie du puy
on trouve de quoi quel sens chemin quoi
et les bancs à l'évent on est bien à
cibler ça n'existait pas de montant dans
les stations comment était-il rct des
bancs en bois puis y en avait pas
tellement il y avait par c'était moins
spacieux que à plaisance tout le monde
ne s'asseyait ça comme ça et c'était
celui qui a taillé que ce soit la
plaisance et voudrait prêter surprise
d'avoir des poissonneuses si parce que
de montreuil avec celle enfin je sais
exactement que si les supprimer de payer
quelques temps et morpho ce qui se passe
le lacet c'est pas mal se conclure avec
les piquet est ce qu'on avait des
contacts avec des voyageurs avec les
contrôleurs
oui puis on en sera sans s'attacher en
impression mais s'est longtemps dans la
même station les voyageurs étaient
gentils avec vous il vous dit un petit
mot quand il faisait froid et on vous
aime bien la nôtre vous dit autre chose
en ferrain finissiez parce qu'on est ce
un moyen sûr si on était juin
on n'a pas fait moi je n'y ai pas été
beaucoup choqué beaucoup là désinv voilà
je suis de la caisse et quand vous étiez
prince on est juste vous faisait quand
les et des resquilleurs
on essayait les palets laissez passer
ont fusé même sont possibles en appeler
chef il arrive des fois ci c'était un
mauvais subjugué aux les biens possédés
mais on se laissait pas fait longtemps
que possible les voyages elle essayait
de passer des enfants qui n avaient qu
il y avait plus que l'âge il n'est passé
sur la caisse mais là on le disait cet
enfant la caisse
il n'a pas l'âge et les tout-petits
enfin voilà ce moment là on essayait de
l'épreuve
si vous voulez pas nous payer en essayer
que le chef italien qu'est ce que c'est
cet appareil monsieur c'est un appareil
qui permet de contrôler des titres de
transport dont les informations que
nécessaire leurs contrôles sont codés
sur une piste magnétique
lorsque le voyageur achète son billet
son billet donc d'un côté si vous voulez
imprimer pour qu'il ait certaines
informations qu'ils publient cern
de l'autre côté il porte une piste
magnétique sur cette piste et un certain
nombre d'informations qui sont codées et
qui vont permettre à la machine de
reconnaître ce billet
lorsque voyageurs mais son billet dans
l'appareil ce message magnétique et donc
lui par une tête de lecture
il est transmis aux auteurs culhat
heures qui lui l'analyse détermine si le
billet est valable lorsque ces îles à
déterminer la valeur du billet il
renvoie un ordre sur le lecteur pour
déverrouiller le bras ce qui était un
mot voyageurs de passer ce mois ci biais
des pas valable le calculateur reconnaît
également comme tel et s'oppose à la
manoeuvre du bras sur l'ensemble du
réseau il ya environ 16 sans contrôle
magnétique noté stations sont équipées
266 station à l'heure actuelle dans un
jour ouvrable on contrôle environ 3
millions 800 mille voyageurs
l'appellation du passage des bisous
qu'un premier temps l'opération est très
courte faire à partir du moment où un
voyageur mais son billet dans le
contrôle il ressort une seconde après et
le traitement propre de ceux du message
des informations me semble
et dur un dixième de seconde
chaque conte crown est relié au centre
de calcul par deux fils ce centre est
composé de douze calculateur et c'est le
centre
à l'heure actuelle qui est le plus grand
centre au monde dans le domaine du temps
réel les élèves conducteurs après leur
stage d'instruction professionnels
subissent une série d'épreuves ayant
trait notamment à la prévention des
accidents
toujours dans le souci d'assurer au
mieux la sécurité des voyageurs n'existe
pas sur le plan non c'est une station
qui était désaffecté nous nous en
servons uniquement pour faire
l'instruction de nos chefs de train et
formation des producteurs en rond et
également une dérivation vers la
l'enclenchement automatique des
compresseurs à chaque extrémité des
voitures un robinet d'accouplement de
conduite générale et comment se passe
cette formation professionnelle
écoutez l'information en particulier du
conducteur que se faire de différentes
façons la première c'est le concours
maintenant pour nous la deuxième c'est
la formation qui évidemment continue 3
rhône
premièrement admettent de l'ère de la
conduite générale dans le réservant aux
auxiliaires deuxième mort pour le
freinage du réservant auxiliaires dans
le sillage de frein puis pour vider
cette ère du synode de frein vers l'air
libre je vais procéder à une
interrogation
tenez vous monsieur par exemple vous
pouvez vous me dire quelle est la
contenance des réservoirs principaux
oui la constance de chacun d'eux alors
là par exemple avec le matériel moderne
nous sommes appelés à supprimer un
certain nombre de chefs de train il est
bien entendu que ces agents il faut
arriver à les recycler en 8 pouvez vous
me dire où se trouve cet appareil et
combien
occupé de position 4e position 4e
position en effet
[Musique]
les uns optent pour les ateliers
d'autres optent pour autre chose et
d'autres demandes des conducteurs et
troisièmement nous avons le recrutement
extérieur bon chef de train est ce que
c'est vous qui avez ouvert un frein de
secours alors je les programmes de
secours
bon bien écouter et vous allez allez
voir dans les voitures si quelqu'un on
n'a pas actionné le frein de secours
alors ensuite mais le coût de sa grille
ou serrer tous les freins à main de tout
ce que nous demandons surtout nous nos
conducteurs c'est d'avoir beaucoup de
réflexes
parce qu'évidemment c'est très important
pour qu'ils puissent collaborer
efficacement
surtout maintenant avec le pcc c'est
pour ça que vous faites ces examens
pratiques
louis nous avons un autre examen un jury
qui se compose deux inspecteurs et un
minimum de deux délégués syndicaux pour
voir leurs connaissances alors là nous
délivre le permis de conduire c'est à
dire le permis de conducteur
nous mettons le conducteur le futur
conducteur dans les mêmes conditions que
s'il était en ligne avec voyageurs il
doit résoudre les incidents comme s'ils
étaient en ligne
les incidents que vous prendre pour que
doux provoque en nous même temps vu qu
est ce que les femmes peuvent être
conductrice nous n'avons rien à priori
contre et peut-être que dans l'avenir il
est fort possible que sur les matériels
modernes on voit des femmes conducteur
pour l'instant non
nous retrouvons messieurs gâche à la
villette garde stockage et de triage
d'où partent les trains de travaux
d'entretien
les ateliers les gags sont les anciens
ateliers du matériel roulant qui ont été
reconverties et spécialisée uniquement
l'usagé exclusif du service de la loi
sur le plan de l'atelier nous fabriquons
ici 10 à 15000 traverse par an nous
utilisons pour l'entretien général du
réseau
la ratp 2200 rails de 18 mètres de long
des routes et pèse 52 kilos au mètre et
nous utilisons diminue tonnes de ballast
à l'intérieur de cet atelier pour les
besoins du réseau nous fabriquons
environ 25 à 30 appareils de voie par an
c'est ici que se font tous les
chargements pour tous les services de la
régie pour tout le matériel autres te
l'avouer par exemple des escaliers
mécaniques l'étoile-club les matériaux
de toutes sortes pour les travaux de
génie civil plus tels que le ciment les
planches et tout ce qu'on a besoin pour
l'entretien du réseau
parce que c'est à partir 10 cycles par
tous les trains de travaux qui vont
travailler la nuit dans le souterrain
combien partout par jour dans les
périodes d'activité intense qui
correspondent par exemple celle de la
mise sur une usine il ya certaines
grandes opérations
on a aussi constaté le soir environ 25 à
28 dollars
[Musique]
la nuit de taper rations sont multiples
alors si vous voulez on peut essayer de
les résumer cette fois bien facile parce
que la liste très longue elle serait pas
exhaustive sur le plan de la voyait les
opérations dites de révision générale de
la voile qui consiste à changer les
traverses changer toutes les attaches ou
tout au moins les vérifier les attaches
deron les renouvellements dry leur
nouvellement de ballast qu'elle fait
d'opérations extrêmement délicate
on a encore beaucoup de chantiers avec
une main-d'oeuvre humaine mais pour
l'instant on ne peut pas faire autrement
on cherchait mais on y ait froid on a
également des conditions impératives des
conditions de travail extrêmement brève
on ne peut travailler que la nuit et
faut que tous les trains et quitter les
chantiers pour 4 h 45 le matin où elle
est donc que c'est des conditions de
travail tout à fait spécial forte
onéreuse et qu'ils limitent l'importance
du travail qu'on peut faire chaque nuit
pour fixer les idées on peut renouveler
la nuit environ 10 minutes de voir par
comparaison info la sncf on a des
chantiers maintenant qui avance à la
cadence de deux kilomètres par jour
je suis vu la proximité du souterrain
l'environnement que le troisième reich
la nécessité de s'approvisionner
uniquement par nos convois qui doivent
donc arriver avec la présence du courant
coupé le courant
toutes ces opérations demandent du temps
[Musique]
à
alors on a des machines spéciales
l'effort de mécanisation l'a quand même
fait et on essaie d'en tirer le meilleur
parti d'abord pour les questions des
questions proprement voix en utilisent
des bourgs aux mécaniques de ballast qui
permet lorsque la voix et 9 de faciliter
le pansement du ballast et le calage de
la voix
[Applaudissements]
nous avons également une draisine
d'auscultation de la voie qui nous
permet de sculpter la loi c'est à dire
de relever les différents paramètres les
bouches des rolls l'écartement le dévers
les voix dans les courbes et qui permet
donc de vérifier toutes ces voix d'en
avoir un enregistrement graphique et
ensuite d'intervenir à bonne escient à
partir des renseignements que la
draisine nous a fournie
nous disposons également d'un temps
inspirateur qui a pour objet de nettoyer
d'enlever les poussières d'enlever tous
les détritus ce qu'ils peuvent tomber
sur la voie
tickets mégots dans une bouteille
journaux c'est vrai et qui enlève
également la poussière dans le
souterrain
chaque fois qu'un voyageur jette par
mégarde volontairement son ticket et
loin des goûts sur la web
il faut penser qu'ils aient ensuite
qu'il faut les ramasser et c'est l'objet
de ce train inspirateur qui arrive à
faire tout le réseau sensiblement deux
fois dans l'année
la maîtrise gabarit serra propre et bien
à chaque fois qu'on met un nouveau
matériel en service on est obligé de
penser un véhicule qu'on appelle la
maquette est une plateforme sur laquelle
on monte des mannequins qui représentent
les parties principales de la caisse on
passe ce matériel sur tout le réseau
pour vérifier et l'engagement
les obstacles et ex la trans'roller nous
avions parlé tout à l'heure de
l'entretien de la voie est bien
on a toujours une forte usure
ondulatoire du raïs qui est extrêmement
désagréable non seulement pour le voyage
hommes pour les riverains pour nos
voyageurs
ça provoque des vibrations dans la
voiture mais ces vibrations se
transmettent aux souterrains aux parois
des souterrains monde dans les îles
mèdes et gêne considérablement les
riverains qui habitent au dessus du
métro alors nous avons un nouveau train
qu'on appelle le transpromo que nous
avons en location et qui travaille avec
des mots de rotatives et à un rendement
excellent alors ce train travail ont
maintenu une vitesse
4 à 110 kilomètres à l'heure et
redonnera une forme d'oiseau de la
fronde comité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et l'entretien des ouvrages d'art alors
l'entretien des ouvrages verts se fait
par un service spécial et ce service à
sa charge le bon état de conservation de
tous le tunnel et de toutes les stations
et également de tous les accès du métro
alors ça c'est une activité très
importante il faut donc que ces travaux
soient coordonnés la nuit pour que tout
le monde puisse parler
[Applaudissements]
l'ennemi sur le métro on a relevé
certains jours d'hiver environ 1300
agents qui travaillent sur l'ensemble de
l'année quand même considérable 1300
c'est quand même l'effectif déjà d'une
belle usine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il n'est pas d'anecdotes racontées sur
les personnes qui mènent sur les persos
monde connaît le nom qu'on peut vous
raconter c'est sur la consolidation des
ouvrages là de temps en temps mais des
surprises pourraient bien sûr un tunnel
sa vigueur il faut apporter des soins
entourage vers le tunnel du métro de
paris maintenant un âge moyen enseigne
importants et en particulier et on a des
idées qu elle maintenant qu'ils ont 65
ans d'âge et à partir de 60 ans lire
d'école de tunnels manifestent des
signes de fatigue du projet renforcée
alors dans ces cas là on n'a qu'un seul
moyen c'est surtout à cette époque ça
consistait à faire des injections d
injection de ciment dans les endroits où
on avait les plus tôt on a donc fait ça
un jour et puis
on s'apercevait qu'il y avait une
fissure qu'on n'arrivait pas à boucher
entend y apporter
witten tenu et on ne pourrait toujours
par le fond de cette fissure jusqu'au
jour où on a reçu une lettre la
direction vers al de la ratp et c'était
le propriétaire du restaurant le [ __ ]
qui se plaignait qu'on avait purement et
simplement bure et sa cave envahit toute
sa case en particulier vous et et les
vins les gens les plus précieux et je
pense que ces bouteilles sont toujours
en y aurait donc six mois seulement
alors là sont dans les travaux qui sont
en cours actuellement sont dans les
travaux de prolongement de la ligne de
soho châtelet on est en train
actuellement de descendre et de faire
des sondages est de faire les travaux
préparatoires la prolongation de la
ligne d'assaut du depuis luxembourg
jusqu'au châtelet justement on passe à
côté de la place saint michel on passe à
côté de la préfecture de police
et naturellement on est obligé dans ses
puits de pomper l'eau et on en a un à un
certain endroit on en comptait une
quantité et concours est prodigieuse et
on se demandait bien pourquoi jusqu'au
moment où la pratique de la police s'est
aperçu qu'on avait vidé ses réserves sa
cité en soutane c'est à dire que la
provision d'eau de réserve le parquet
pierre de police nous l'avons pompe est
rejetée en scène
à la bastille nous découvrons le
chantier de percement du tunnel de
liaison rer avec la future gare du
simplet cette machine destinée
essentiellement faire un tunnel très
dire thermiquement d'escalation
themachine on a voulu très simple ce qui
fait que un fait uniquement du trou
c'est un engin pas banal parce qu'il y
en a très peu dans le monde encore le
tènement mais qui fesse des mètres de
tunnel et toutes les fonctions arrière
destinée à terminer à compléter le
chantier les tunnels sont et
indépendamment par une succession de
partie que autonome et complètement dit
joint de la machine man c'est une
machine qui indiqueront le progrès mise
en place cette machine tourne les pouces
si vous voulez un petit peu à la manière
d'une perceuse une danse ou de bricoleur
avec évidemment une échelle encore
complètement différente des machines
tournent un contre le terrain et votre
rotative la machine qui est au contact
du terrain et munis d'outils qui détruit
le terrain et cette avance discontinue
permet ainsi de faire des avancements
qui sont de l'ordre de 1 m peut être le
quart d'heure 1 le chantier se
développent un rythme moyen normal de
deux mètres à l'heure à la machine
elle-même il ya douze personnes
seulement par poste de travail de huit
heures ce qui est évidemment extrêmement
en volume la section m'être fait environ
40 mètres cubes au mètre linéaire du
tunnel et si l'on pense que la machine
peut avancer et en pointe de 30 mètres
jours ça fait
800 mètres cubes de déblais qui sont
sortis tous les jours dit vouloir la
bastille
[Musique]
il y a cinq mètres cubes de béton au
maître des tunnels et non bétonne
systématiquement tous les jours quelle
que soit l'avancement d'ailleurs la
chine 20 mai de revêtement définitif par
jour ça fait donc environ 100 mètres
cubes de béton qui sont mis en place
toujours le village de la machine se
fait à l'aide d'un rayon laser mais il
ne fait que matérialiser la visée d'un
géomètre si vous vous laissez de rayons
laser ce qu'un petit peu leur corps
d'autres jardiniers grands chantiers
qu'on tire d'un point à un autre de
manière à avoir une référence qui permet
au conducteur de machine qui est assisté
toujours d'ailleurs l'un d'un opérateur
géomètre
on a un tracé qui très compliqué avec
beaucoup de courbes
le tracé est compliqué donc le guidage
est difficile et le résultat c'est que
le tunnel est guidé avec moins d'un
centimètre d'erreur ce qui est quand
même assez creux ordinaire
[Musique]
la ratp a été la première en europe en
1963 à utiliser ce type de matériel et
la machine utilisée par la régie à
l'époque était la panne dont non
seulement la première d'europe mais la
plus complexe jamais construite au monde
les danses et liam est là puisque les
diamètres chemins de fer la machine des
toiles faisait plus de dix mètres de
diamètre extérieur parce que le tunnel
contenait deux trains le tunnel de
liaison entre ch est l'égard des lions
lui est un tunnel à voie unique donc les
plus petites et s'appelle de la m mais
même sept mètres de diamètre c'est une
grosse machine
si vous voulez la régie en france a le
privilège des grosses machines
le chantier lui-même sera terminée au
début 1976 et il a démarré au pour
l'instant les premier semestre 1972 le
pcc appelle la ram qui arriva concorde
et sur la rue
et
[Musique]
c'est pour un essai du radiotéléphone
comment savez vous je vous remercie
madame david savez-vous nous sommes nous
sommes au pcc du métro et qu'est ce que
c'est que le pcc ben c'est le poste de
commandement de communication que
signifient les lettres pcc alors poste
de commande centralisé c'est la première
dame éléphants gibier je suis étonné
parce que c'est quelque chose de leur
dire comment ça se passe est votre temps
armé de mon temps les s'il y avait un
incident chaque chef s'occuper de son
coin et comment faisait-il et ben si
c'était un incident de teint et coupé le
courant déjà éliminé la permanence oui
le chef de secteur se déplaçait venez
voir ce qui s'est passé sur le terrain
c'est à dire hey combien de temps ça
dépend des fois c'est et ça ne dirais
pas comme des fois ça a duré longtemps
c'est dégagé
et l'arrivée sur la ligne 6 il avait
pendant l'hiver les rames avaient du mal
à passer du côté de bercy y avait une
rampe là si je lui aussi léger il
arrivait une est restée en panne alors
là le sous-chef prévenu le chef de
secteur qui a laissé place aux verts 6
passes et il arrivait que il fallait un
autre train qui a poussé celui là où la
patrie et les voyageurs alors nous
sommes ici dans le poste de commande
centralisé nous avons là commandes de
toutes les lignes du réseau au point de
vue régularisation des commandes en
cours entre action j'ai la possibilité
de ce pupitre de couper le courant si
besoin s'en fait sentir de réalimenter
partiellement certaines sections de
lignes ou bouby éventuellement de
tourner des trains à l'aide des
diagonales que nous avons qui sont
commandés directement du but du tc haut
que nous avons en face de façon à
rétablir partiellement le trafic sur une
ligne qu'elle est en intervalle entre
deux rames
alors le temps d'intervalle entre deux
rames le soir et dure une minute 35
secondes et un période de creux en
période de crue trois minutes et demie
3,35 à peu près trois quarts par exemple
nous prenons une rame qui partant le
matin mettons à 8h10 35 va rencontrer
dans chaque station une pendule de
régulation qui veulent mieux indiqués 10
35 simplement les minutes et les
secondes et il devra se tenir en règle
avec leur au départ leur donner au
départ de son terminus
reste à stx y prend de l'avancé
lorsqu'il point de l'avancement rôle à
moi serait de le retenir éventuellement
sur la carte courant alors la france du
point de 750 volts en sortir at il
ajouté en de façon de pouvoir couper le
courant nous ont coupé le courant à la
demande d'un conducteur en faisant du
picou des six dg direction générale je
coupe le courant sur toute la ligne
ou alors en actionnant une barrette
dollars ont été dépensés alors à ce
moment là le courant sera coupée dans la
section intéressés et quand il ya des
agressions
est ce qu'on pouvait faire quelque chose
lorsqu'il ya des agressions et bien ma
foi nous essayons d'intervenir plus
rapidement possible auprès de la
préfecture de police ont envoyé des
personnels qualifiés c'est leur visage
entre lyss
mais je serai informé de ce fait au
moyen du téléphone hautes fréquences que
nous avons eu rien à cette salle nous
sommes un parent par ligne et ça que le
service fonctionnant 24 heures sur 24
nous faisons donc les trois-huit nous
sommes donc trois voies sur un service
journalier nous avons une très grande
responsabilité à ce moment là car
évidemment une fausse manoeuvre
entraînerait des accidents très graves
au point de vue de la sécurité du
personnel qui travaille sur les voies ou
ses passes d'entretien du matériel
roulant
il faut distinguer entre deux entretiens
de ce kit d'entretien qui ait lieu que
dans tous les huit jours se fait dans
des ateliers situés d'une manière
générale à une extrémité de la ligne et
le grand entretien centralisés dans
quatre attaques grands ateliers qui sont
les ateliers de saint jouin les ateliers
de choisy et de vaugirard et l'atelier
de fontenay situés à l'ouest
chacun de ces ateliers est capable de
démonter toutes les voitures de faire
toutes les révisions les réparations
importantes
et puis alors vous avez également les
ateliers propre au métro régional où
l'ancien atelier de bruges pour la ville
de sceaux et puis l'atelier de boissy
pour le rer avec 4 pellemans sur la
branche ouest également pour la ligne de
saint germain
l'atelier dorval
[Musique]
la verrière tel que nous le connaissons
avec ses normes actuelles a été
réellement défi en 1961 et les voitures
sont aussi beaucoup plus grande que
celle qui t'arrive de son plus grand
bien sûr parce que y
parce que leur mère a été conçu pour ne
pas avoir de courbes d'arion inférieur à
500 m exceptionnellement pour cent
mètres de riom ce matériel est en forte
capacité peut transporter 2500 voyageurs
par rame de neuf voitures ce qui va
donner avec un intervalle moyen de 2
minutes 30 secondes d'une capacité de
lob de 50 mille voyageurs par heure et
par sens pour
et lumière à verre
coin sont les travaux d'exploitation du
métro en province je la première vie qui
a commencé les travaux c'est marseille
les travaux de lyon actuellement sont
également en plein développement et dans
les années qui viennent ces réseaux vont
ouvrir et d'ailleurs ces deux villes ont
finalement retenu la technique qui a été
utilisé à paris et ça serait du matériel
sur pneus moderne
d'ailleurs avec une constitueront encore
plus moderne que le métissage puisque là
on va partir sur un réseau entièrement
neuf lots techniques en compétition avec
d'autres techniques étrangères
intéressante également arrive dans bien
des cas de l'emporter
madame david c'est la première fois que
voyager à bord de la cabine de pilotage
oui quel effet ça vous a fait ben on va
parler drôle parce que je n'avais pas
l'habitude mais je me suis trouvé très
bien
le conducteur m'a bien conseillé on va
demander quoi ça se faisait j'étais là
si j'étais la ratp les découvrir il dit
moi aussi dit je viens d'hôtel et à
présent je suis saint germain dit ça
change de l'urbain on a parlé comme ça
le moins qu'on ait un ensemble que vous
avez traité très simplifié au point du
conduit sallèles bien simplifié est vrai
pas été surprise dans la vitesse à la
vitesse aussi mais en face on encore
lire des médias tour ivan c'est bien
quand même
les métros se vend bien puis son
silencieux aussi à présent
[Musique]
c'est beau doutez-vous quoi désagréable
conquérir de cette façon de s'asseoir
l'attend là tout à côté d' intenses du
monde du lien et l'éclairage à la seule
elle même m'a sauté aux yeux parce que
cet éclairage ce plafond cette façon de
c'est elles mettront vos rêves vous
imaginez comme ça oui et non joue tant
que je n'étais pas loin du compte mais à
présent je vois ce que çà s'est
[Musique]